president biden says he will nominate a
successor to the supreme court justice
stephen breyer by the end of next month
he has also reaffirmed that that nominee
will be a black woman calling it long
overdue
breyer confirmed yesterday that he will
retire after nearly 28 years on the high
court senate democratic leaders say the
confirmation process will be quick
weisha zhang is at the white house with
more on that story i guess the question
is how quick is quick good morning to
you
good morning to you gail and good
morning to everybody as soon as possible
if you ask democrats now president biden
is very familiar with this confirmation
process he has a lot of experience
overseeing six hearings for supreme
court justices when he was the chairman
of the senate judiciary committee now he
says he is not only looking for the
senate's consent but it's advice to help
him decide who will make history
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity cbs
news has learned that president biden
does have some names in mind to replace
justice stephen breyer the short list
includes federal appeals court judge
katanji brown jackson a harvard law
school graduate and a former clerk for
breyer and california supreme court
justice leandra krueger a yale law
school graduate then california attorney
general kamala harris was on the
committee that confirmed her but
congressman jim clyburn a close ally of
mr bidens is pushing for federal judge
michelle childs who graduated from the
university of south carolina school of
law clyburn said childs non-ivy league
background is an asset she has
what i call
the kind of background and experiences
that we ought to have democrats want to
move fast to fill the seat breyer will
vacate at the end of the term this
summer a simple majority vote is enough
to confirm a nominee and it looks
promising for mr biden west virginia
senator joe manchin said he's open to
supporting someone more liberal than he
as far as just their philosophical
beliefs no that doesn't that will not
prohibit me from supporting somebody but
before he names a nominee to replace
justice breyer president biden praised
him as a model public servant who had
these parting words on democracy my
grandchildren and their children they'll
determine whether the experiment still
works and of course i am an optimist and
i'm pretty sure it will
president biden says he will also
consult with leading scholars and
attorneys in the selection process
adding that vice president kamala harris
will play a key role in advising him for
his part senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell says he will give the nominee
a fair look but warned against
outsourcing the decision to the quote
radical left nate
we do thank you